I don't have education no I'm saying you
had the right people around you
you know what I'm trying to say no
everyone's going back you choose but
okay at 18 that's an excuse but at 40
you pick you surround yourself so I'm
gonna give you an example one time I
decided I wanted more rich friends I
literally was just like my friends are
too broke I'm on a bunch of brokies
and so you know I lived I lived in
Milwaukee at the time and I worked I
worked a sales job so I was like you
know what I want to just see if I can
call some of these numbers and see if
any of these Executives because I
definitely I was trying to sell copier
sentiment one to meet with me but I was
like I'm gonna see if they'll get coffee
with me and just like um and see if they
can mentor me ask them about their
success I got three c-level Executives
of multi-million dollar companies to
literally sit down spend 30 minutes with
me just by asking and yes and I agree
another time another time this is for a
YouTube video right I was just bored one
day and you know people will always you
know say it's because I'm a girl or
because of this or because of that
whatever but like honestly I I feel like
I could do this with anyone I I um I did
this for a YouTube video I didn't have a
job because I quit my job to be a tick
tocker I know and yeah I quit I was
working in sales and I was doing quite
well but I just quit it to do to do Tick
Tock and I moved home with my parents
and um I was like maybe I'll see if I
could find a job in a day so I went to
this rich neighborhood um and it's by
Chicago it's like where all the rich
people are and I was like I wonder if I
go door to door I like snuck into the
Gated area I know and um I was like I
wonder if I go door to door in this
neighborhood and just ask people for a
job within one day I got an interview
for a sales job now I didn't want the
job so I didn't end up taking it because
I was just trying to do YouTube but but
the point is like it's all about like
you can you have two choices in life
like everything can be an excuse
I came here 13 years ago I was learning
I only had a hundred dollars in my
pocket
but it is because honestly the people
and I'm telling you I'm around these
people the people that are really
successful they don't talk about that
they just talk about what they're doing
they're so excited about this next
project this this and this yeah I'm
excited about it and maybe and maybe you
are but I'm saying the way you've
represented yourself in this
conversation is it's always an excuse
It's like it's
excuse is a very impossible
it's describing what it is it's
describing it's wait wait it's
describing outcomes and it's like you've
had 13 years outcomes I had to deal with
everyone's got stuff to deal with what
did you have to deal with that it's none
of them it's not nobody I I came to this
country by myself well alone I didn't
know anyone in this country so I mean
have other people had it harder did you
have it harder sure but I'm telling you
I know people in worse situations that
made more so I don't know I feel like
you're talking from a privileged place
yes
and I'll tell you I'm talking about
generation I'm talking about no no no no
I'm talking from a privileged place and
being around these types of people so I
can tell you the people that have had
good outcomes and I know people that
have had good outcomes for wait I know
people that have had good outcomes from
the bottom I've known people that have
had good outcomes from the top and I can
tell you the way they talk isn't the way
you talk because because they're not
always talking about the reasons they
didn't succeed they're talking about
because of the question you've got to
answer questions though you know I mean
you got to I'm answering the questions
that you're putting out there you know
have you got a boyfriend no how old are
you 39. so I'm responding you know if
you ask me now okay what do you do now
nobody's asked me that you only be like
oh you're making making excuses I'm not
I'm revolving the information you gave
you offered it was it didn't really have
much to do every question I had a
question I believe did you want to raise
your you go to your hand raise yeah I
just wanted to add to her point about uh
you don't haven't uh don't have any
bills to pay when you're 18 living with
your parents but uh everyone has their
situations and in fact uh during the
coronavirus I was maybe like 19 I had to
basically uh pay for the whole family my
mom and dad went out of business and I
was the only man in the house that was
earning money and providing for the
house so there is different things that
people go through and again you can't
judge on them and I'm not trying to
judge you and to your point that you had
a hundred pounds in your account when
you came here to be fair you don't
really need money to make money as long
as you're willing to do I feel like
they're in this conversation we're
trying to put the finger on each person
and be like oh are you this you did like
each person is different each person yes
so each person different like I say what
I would say although we're all having
conversations and we're sharing
experience and stuff about our own lives
we feel like we're being vulnerable
because we're showing information
actually I don't see that anybody here
it might feel like people are being
personally attacked but it's not and I'm
hearing like I can hear that you're
feeling a bit maybe getting a bit
defensive because I don't think yeah I
agree words are powerful but it's also
words that are down to interpretation so
somebody could say to me that I'm making
an excuse I'm not going to be defensive
at somebody saying I'm making an excuse
that might make me think to myself okay
could I have done something more could I
have done this okay it's all how we how
we take it and how we understand and it
so everyone's circumstances are their
own there's no competition as you said
maybe you felt like Pearl was talking
from a place of privilege somebody else
might think that you're talking from a
place of privilege you know everyone's
circumstances and situations are their
own all you have to do is know that
you're doing the best that you can do
but it's also very important that you
need to be realistic I think that I
think as soon as we start being honest
with ourselves and truthful with
ourselves about where we lack where we
could do more where we need to be more
disciplined or the changes that we need
to make then you will really see like a
a propeller of energy and you will go
into the area that you want to go in but
I think that people spend a lot of time
procrastinating and hesitating and I'm
not saying that you are doing that but
people do spend a lot of time
procrastinating hesitating they're not
in the right circles they're not having
the right influences but they still
believe that they're going to achieve
the things that they want to achieve
that's okay you can still believe that
but I don't think that you I don't think
that the word excuse was supposed to be
an attack on you I think excuses what a
lot of people do yeah it is what people
do but you gotta you gotta you gotta
look at the Timeline you know but that's
just for your person so that's for your
person I could have probably done this a
bit more I could have done this I could
have went College earlier but at the end
of the day you don't know the challenges
one has to face to make me end up and
sickness to you guys
you know Pearl right you know I know
Pearl you've met no I've met her today
you have a wonderful you have a
wonderful example of somebody that came
to a new country that has created a
significance I've met you today because
now I'm evolving around these
significant following significant future
yeah but it's like give you I tell you
something and you argue it and you argue
ground up because I know my heart and if
you're saying oh you make the excuses
I've had successful people tell me that
before and my reaction is oh you're
probably right because they know
something you don't
or anything but I'm a very strong woman
and I Will Stand My Ground and I would
like to be heard and I'm going to be
heard regardless I want you to
understand not even understand I want
you to overstand like the way you did
you know you know the type of background
I'm coming from if I tell you some
horror stories that I've done yeah it
will it will I had to change my
mentality I had to deal
I get the process and I get how and it's
different for different people it's
upbringing and how we've also been
taught how to deal with certain
situations in life if we're not taught
initially just by not sorting out
certain situations we go back so that's
where people get some Advantage
somewhere people get disadvantaged and
it is what it is Journeys are journeys
imagine you changing your mentality and
you're going back to your friends that
you used to speak to in 16 18 20 and
you're telling them the journey who
don't even understand it and you think
to yourself you know what I need new
friends I need I ain't gonna lie
so I can speak to them you're not girl
just don't understand just being plus
size right I'm not even gonna lie in
different weight changes I was being
treated differently so that just goes to
show like when I saw pre-pandemic I
became 28 songs I got ill so I was 28
stones and I'm not gonna allow people
are really being mean to me and I'm a
person who I'm a quite a happy cheery
person I love speaking to elderly people
on the tube and just talking to people
and making conversation but when I lost
that way I'm telling you after pandemic
I lost eight stones and people treated
me differently and I'm never gonna lie
even business like a lot of people come
up to and be like oh my God you've got
something and we'd like to work with you
so we just goes to show how sometimes by
looks and how you are people also you
have to be the change that people will
believe
what do you mean like you got to be the
change see I just sometimes you guys are
saying things and I feel like they mean
nothing no so that's because if you feel
the hardship and the and if you feel the
heart if you've been to through the
hardship and you've gone through the
cycle of actually okay getting Gap from
this hardship then you'd you'd
understand the feeling if you don't
understand the feeling if you haven't
gone through the process it's really
hard to understand hey it's not about
the feeling like if we're talking about
success right and we're talking about
business success it's what what are you
doing so I'll give you an example when I
first started this all right it was just
me it was in a living room in a small
apartment in East London and I was
running to the gym trying to get people
to get the gym to come on my podcast and
then I could say this is what I'm doing
but it's like when we talk about oh
there's a feeling we're evolving
mentally it's like it's like what is it
that's what I'm saying you've come from
a privileged person but your mindset has
been amazing for you I had to change my
mindset babe you're 39. this is like a
conversation with a 60s and I started
changing my mindset say about 27 28 when
I realized that I had to deeper okay as
a teenager
like
so but but what are the results like
that's my thing the results is you you
still can't have a conversation without
without getting defensive and it's like
you need to be right I'm telling when
you're being attacked from people that
don't know your life story
then no but give me the right word
across a little bit defensive and the
topic was yeah the subject was about
profession like in business being
successful in business you want to be
yeah so so but but what you but the
conversation has gone into like a
spiritual journey
that's not business that's totally
separate logically yeah
basically I I get what you're saying
everything's about feelings emotions but
that's not what business is about but
sometimes people actually don't know
business and they need to learn their
lessons and then they get business and
then they flourish and I think that's
where she's coming from and I get your
point as well because I get it when you
say but you're talking about feelings
and things but feelings get involved
when you learn a lesson and then you
need to try again get back up fail try
again so is that what happened to you I
don't know you don't need to answer
actually don't want to reprogram so as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible